so Republicans did a nice little job of
executing a sort of temporary corporate
media coup yesterday this is when what I
don't mean they took over ownership of
corporate media what I mean is they took
over the attention of corporate media
when they pulled an obviously
unnecessary and just ridiculous
political stunt that was meant again to
take over coverage of corporate media
for the day and they did it about 30
Republicans stormed a closed-door
meeting yesterday as a protest of what
they said was being shut out of Trump's
impeachment inquiry what they said was a
lack of transparency the specific
meeting was one where Laura Cooper the
Deputy Secretary of Defense was going to
testify Republicans are saying none of
this is legit Democrats are holding
secret private meetings it's all bad
Republicans reportedly storming in and
taking pictures in the meeting so that
then the entire thing was delayed it had
to be swept by police for security
breaches and it ended up being a total
childish display of nonsense and in the
end it served only to delay Lisa
Cooper's testimony by a few hours it
didn't prevent it but it did succeed at
getting Republicans some undeserved
attention but here's the absurdity and I
wasn't even going to cover this until I
learned about this these Republicans are
saying the reason they did this is
there's a lack of transparency that
they're being shut out of the
impeachment process this is an inquiry
that is being run by the house
intelligence Oversight and Foreign
Affairs committees there are Republicans
on those committees Republicans on those
committees can ask questions at every
hearing they can review documents if
they so choose the entire pretext or
pretense of this protest and barging in
is completely bogus and Axios looked
into the details thirteen is so crazy
thirteen of the Republicans who
participated in this protest are on the
committee's in question they can
question witnesses they can review
documents thirteen of the Republicans
stormed a meeting in protest over lack
of inclusion
and transparency despite the fact that
they are already involved themselves in
the inquiry it was 100% a stunt
corporate media of course fell for it
and that's why I hesitated to cover it I
got a lot of tweets saying David you've
got to talk about this protest you've
got to talk about Republicans barging in
you've got to cover the protests itself
the reason I wasn't sure is because it
was such a patently bogus stunt but in
the end I decided you know it's
important to explain first because lots
of those Republicans have access that
they claim to be demanding that it's a
complete and total sham of a protest but
also there's you know with Donald
everything around Donald Trump seems to
include not only lies and distortions
and personal motivations but witness
tampering has been a big big part of
everything that Donald Trump has done
around any investigation or attempt to
just exert oversight that is legally a
possibility for Democrats this could be
argued to be a form of witness tampering
because this is okay the Deputy
Secretary of Defense I'm guessing that
she's not going to be intimidated by
this but when you're already directing
people to ignore subpoenas when you
already want to suppress witnesses who
could speak not about the great things
you've done but about the problematic
things that you've done that they've
overheard seen or witnessed a great way
to indirectly tamper with witnesses and
to maybe influence them to opt out of
participation is to send a signal that
their participation is going to be
disrupted their participation is going
to be difficult that also by the way how
secure was the facility if these
Republicans were able to just barge in
in the middle and now there are
discussion among Democrats of we need
better physical security to protect
ourselves from Republicans who want to
barge in with bogus and ridiculous
protests about things that aren't
actually problems understand the
insanity of that understand the
absurdity of in government buildings
Democrats may need physical security so
that disgruntled brown-nosing sick of
antic Republicans don't interrupt the
legal constitutionally protected
processes and investigations in which
they are participating it almost is
beyond explanation with the normal
English language I don't know how else
to say it do it cappucci paid for de
Gracia Mila one of our sponsors making
the David Pakman show possible is Babel
the language learning app and you'll get
25% off a subscription to Babel when you
click the link under this video
Babel was founded in 2007 and now has
over a million paying subscribers
worldwide as one of the world's leading
language learning apps their learning
method has been examined numerous times
in scientific studies including one at
Yale in 2019 which found that 100
percent of participants who used Babel
were able to improve their oral
proficiency with a new language within
just three months research found that
users learning Spanish on Babel only
needed to use the app for an average of
15 hours over a two-month period to
cover the requirements for one college
semester of Spanish I recently went to
Italy and used Babel to brush up on my
Italian for a few weeks leading up to
the trip and I was actually surprised at
how much I was able to absorb in such a
short amount of time
after practicing Italian on the babble
app I was able to hold some
conversations with locals in Italy I
could understand a lot more of the
Italian that I was hearing and the
progress I made was extremely inspiring
in keeping me going and continuing to
use the app to get even better I'm also
about to use the app to start learning
German which I'm looking forward to I
really would recommend Babel to anyone
who watches our show and you can save
25% on a subscription to Babel when you
click the link right underneath this
video